avec eux la famille mais quand bien même
les enfants pourraient aider les parents
c'est très rare que les parents ils
réalisent abusé lfr travail je dirais
pas que c'est du tout c'était en plein
gré c'est en tout cas c'est du plein gré
des enfants on le voit dans le
documentaire ce qui ne rend pas la
situation plus plus simple pour eux
merci beaucoup à maylis charlas d'avoir
été avec nous pour commenter ce
documentaire de laure dans la boue
diffusé en exclusivité assuré arte
france
je rappelle que vous êtes la directrice
générale de la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie des philippines
vous pourrez retrouver l'intégralité de
notre documentaire sur rt france point
tva bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]
plusieurs milliers de personnes à paris
et partout en france pour rendre hommage
à samuel pâtit ce professeur sauvagement
assassinée à nantes hier à conflans
sainte honorine
le chef de l'état a réuni ce soir un
conseil de défense et il pourrait
annoncer des mesures immédiates
concernant la sécurité dans les écoles
[Musique]
un nouveau record de contamination en
france plus de 32000 cas alors que neuf
métropoles sont sous couvre-feu des
opposants à cette mesure ont manifesté
la nuit dernière à paris et à marseille
il ya eu quelques interpellations et des
dizaines de procès verbaux mais la
majorité des personnes concernées
semblent respecter ses consignes
la guinée votent aujourd'hui pour élire
son président et sauf surprise c'est le
président sortant alpha condé qui
devrait remporter le scrutin
un troisième mandat contesté dans le
pays l'opposition accuse le pouvoir
actuel de dérive autocratique
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce dimanche ces
rassemblements un peu partout en france
aujourd'hui en hommage au professeur tué
avant-hier dans les yvelines pour avoir
montré des caricatures du prophète à ses
élèves
des milliers de personnes à paris vous
le voyez place de la république à
l'appel des syndicats d'enseignants les
responsables des principaux partis
politiques étaient là le premier
ministre jean castex a également tenu à
être présent tout comme son ministre de
l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer
et la ministre déléguée à la citoyenneté
marlène schiappa voyez les précisions
sur place de notre reporter thomas
bronnec plusieurs milliers de personnes
rassemblées sur cette place de la
république pour rendre hommage à samuel
pâtit ce professeur d'histoire
géographie qui est décédé vendredi
assassiné par un terroriste
c'était dans la commune de conflans
sainte honorine beaucoup de personnes
ont tenu donc à se rassembler cet après
midi ici à paris avec des prises de
paroles de différents représentants
d'organisations politiques associatives
ou encore syndicale il avait notamment
des représentants de l'association sos
racisme ou encore des représentants de
parents d'élèves d'enseignants ou
d'étudiants qui ont tour à tour rendu
hommage à la mémoire de samuel pâtit un
petit peu d'agitation lorsque la
représentante de l'unef a pris la parole
on se rappelle qu'il y avait eu quelques
polémiques autour de ce syndicat
étudiant beaucoup de personnalités
politiques également qui avaient fait le
déplacement
on pense notamment au premier ministre
jean castex au ministre de l'éducation
nationale jean michel blanquer ainsi
qu'un certain nombre de députés de
plusieurs partis différents de la
majorité présidentielle ou encore
d'europe écologie les verts mais aucune
prise de parole publique
pour ses représentants politiques
s'étaient vraisemblablement une volonté
de la part des organisateurs et puis en
ce qui concerne les personnes qui ont
fait le déplacement elle s'était donc
plusieurs milliers et des personnes
d'horizons tout à fait différent qui se
sont rassemblés je propose d'écouter
quelques témoignages que nous avons
récoltées cet après midi pour moi ça me
laisse était de martyrs de la liberté
je dis je le répète nous sommes tous
samuel à martin cet acte barbare
malheureusement ça me donne la confiance
en cause de la gravité de l'islamisme
existe qui touche notre jeunesse
lorsqu'elle était de secours comme celle
des séries ou d'autres cellules sont
faits de conséquence d'avoir notre
jeunesse elle de riz elle dit rien on n
y met à devient une menace à la société
et là je pense que c'est notre travail
tous quels que soient les religieux les
laïcs nous travaillons ensemble qu'on
concède pas mais aussi en lutte contre
cette minorité
le pays doit être unie derrière ces
enseignants et le pays doit être uni
pour la démocratie pour la laïcité pour
la liberté d'expression un fils est
aujourd'hui abominable de voir que des
groupes politiques
certains groupes religieux combattent
l'école combattre la laïcité combattre
la démocratie l'école est un sanctuaire
et nous devrons absolument la protéger
ce qui ressort aussi des témoignages que
nous avons pu récolter c'est que passé
ce moment de recueillement et d'hommage
les personnes qui étaient présentes ici
attentes maintenant à des actes forts de
la part des autorités publiques pour en
finir avec cette menace du terrorisme
et puis un mot enfin pour vous dire que
mercredi prochain une journée d'hommage
national sera rendu à semelle pâtit et à
l'issue de ce rassemblement emmanuel
macron réuni ses ministres autour d'un
conseil de défense des mesures
pourraient être annoncées dans la foulée
et vous voyez l'analyse de jean messier
un membre du bureau national du
rassemblement national et de françois
cocq et céistes et ancien orateur de la
france insoumise
il était en débat tout à l'heure que dit
monsieur macron monsieur macron s'assoit
sur la laïcité en nous disant que c'est
un amour et public de former les imams
autrement dit on va aller remettre le
doit à m le temporel qui va aller se
mêler du spirituel
et que font les islamistes ils veulent
justement que le spirituel passe sous la
queue le temporel passe sous la coupe du
spirituel
autrement dit finalement monsieur macro
apporte de l'eau au moulin des
islamistes eh bien il faut rompre avec
tout ça il faut que l'islam prête le
problème qui existe en son sein et pour
le reste la république elle ne doit pas
céder d'un iota le gouvernement peut pas
nous expliquer qui va lutter contre le
séparatisme et outre la limite que
monsieur qu'okami il ya un instant et à
laquelle je souscris à savoir la
formation b
imam etc on peut pas non plus continuer
à ouvrir grandes les vannes de
l'immigration puisque cette immigration
nourrit le séparatisme puisqu'elle est
principalement musulmanes donc à un
moment si vous voulez il faut prendre la
chaîne causale dans son ensemble depuis
sa génèse jusqu'à sa conséquence la plus
terrifiante analysé et décortiqué et
diagnostiquer le problème pour pouvoir
se donner les moyens d'apporter des
mesures efficaces
or si on ne traite que la superficie
épidermique du phénomène c'est à dire
simplement une attaque et on va faire de
la cosmétique et bien c'est se condamner
à revoir les mêmes scènes atroces et
bien se répéter dans les rues de france
et dans nos écoles et dans le collège un
nouveau record de contamination en
france plus de 32000 cas alors que neuf
villes sont sous couvre-feu des
opposants à cette mesure ont d'ailleurs
manifesté la nuit dernière à paris ou à
marseille il ya eu quelques
interpellations et des dizaines de
procès verbaux mais la majorité des
personnes concernées semblent avoir
respecté les consignes voyez la réaction
à cette première nuit de couvre-feu des
parisiens et de certains touristes
présents dans la capitale
je ne pense pas que le couvre-feu à 21h
soit une bonne mesure car lorsque les
gens doivent rentrer à la maison avant
21h il y à beaucoup de monde en même
temps cela va à l'encontre de l'objectif
du couvre-feu et ça éloigne les gens les
uns des autres
c'est une bonne chose parce que de toute
évidence les gens vont en boîte où tout
le monde est coincé ensemble ils vont
boire un verre donc c'est bien parce que
ça stoppe ses événements mais comme l a
dit si tout le monde rentre à 21h il ya
trop de personnes tous vont être proches
les uns des autres
vous pouvez simplement propager le virus
si quelqu'un là que soit ouverte
je pense que c'est une mesure drastique
méditer nécessaire et
quand on est nombreux à le penser
les amis qui
son qui pensent comme moi aujourd'hui
des jeunes et des moins jeunes
mes parents aussi je crois que c'était
nécessaire parce qu'on avait atteint un
pic ont risqué de son voisin dubaï tout
de même 3 0 début d'un couvre-feu qui va
durer au moins quatre semaines alors
qu'un nouveau record je voulais 10 a été
franchie 32400 27,4 contamination à ces
dernières 24 heures hausse également du
taux de positivité à 13,1 contre 9% il
ya seulement dix jours et enfin on
dénombre 90 décès supplémentaires dans
les hôpitaux
c'est jour de vote aujourd'hui en guinée
plus de 5 millions d'électeurs appelés
aux urnes pour élire leur président
douze candidats en lice dont le chef de
l'état sortant alpha condé qui a voté ce
matin à conakry le président guinéen qui
brigue un troisième mandat consécutif
après une campagne plutôt mouvementée
face à son principal opposant cellou
dallen diallo foulée deux candidats qui
ont appelé au calme pour ce scrutin
écouter les souhaits que les années
avic et transparente et que tout se
passe dans de la paix est là
et et nous allons faire en sorte de
sécuriser plus lourd
la guinée peut penser de lui signer
l'appel tu n'as pas leur fait la
sécurité limités je n'ai aucun doute
quant à l'issue du scrutin c'est
pourquoi je ne sais pas que de violences
viennent perturber les scrutins et
compromettent peut-être dans une
certaine mesure
ma victoire et pour en parler nous
serions direct avec aliou barry
chercheur associé à l'institut
prospective et et sécurité en europe
également président du centre d'analysé
d'études stratégiques
bonsoir aliou barry merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur rt france tout
d'abord une réaction la forte
participation aujourd'hui à ce scrutin
comment l'expliquez vous 7
d'abord je vous remercie de m'associer à
l'analyse de la situation politique en
guinée mais certes cet engouement
s'explique pour une raison très simple
depuis les années 90 dates de départ du
multipartisme en guinée
c'est l'un des rares pays d'afrique de
l'ouest qui n'a pas connu une alternance
politique donc aujourd'hui les guinéens
ont soif d'un terrain c'est pourquoi
chaque élection il ya beaucoup
d'engouement et les gens parce que les
gens n'ont jamais connu moi par exemple
ma génération on n'a jamais connu
l'alternance politique en guinée alors
que des pays limitrophes
la guinée qui ensemble qui ont connu des
crises de graves crises politiques comme
le libéria la sierra leone la guinée
bissao la côte d'ivoire le sénégal ont
le plus connu une alternance politique
une alternance démocratique
c'est pourquoi les guinées à chaque
élection se rendent en masse pour voter
il ya également beaucoup d'électeurs qui
disent avoir voté contre
l'ethnocentrisme c'est le fait de
privilégier évidemment l'ethnie de
laquelle on est issu c'est un peu la
marque de fabrique d'alpha condé est ce
que ça aussi les guinéens veulent
tourner la page mais tout en façade et
un petit il faut savoir aussi que
l'histoire politique de ce pays est
remarqué par l'instrumentalisation du
père noël ethnique saddam de béthune et
monsieur sékou touré qui en 1976 avait
déclaré publiquement la guerre open et à
chaque élection depuis 2010 monsieur
alpha condé ressort
la même rhétorique sur l'important le
fait de ne pas permettre à
ressortissants de la communauté peule
d'accéder au pouvoir
cette communauté aujourd'hui devant ce
problème est complètement déterminé et
vote hamas mais il est à mon avis c'est
une erreur de croire que le parti de
l'union des forces démocratiques de
guinée est en partie technique je
trouvais en train depuis l'indépendance
de paix de ce pays jusqu'en 2010
à chaque fois le parti au pouvoir et le
parti majoritaire parce que l'animation
et à la disposition de ce parti un conte
aime ou qu'on n'aime pas monsieur diallo
aujourd'hui il s'avère que c'est la
première fois en afrique de l'ouest
comme parti d'opposition est majoritaire
et malheureusement l'administration et
le processus électoral est tenu par
l'administration
je ne doute pas de l'uci de cette
élection
en tout cas les deux parties ont compté
plaie au calme visiblement l'appel a été
entendu ce qui est critique finalement
celle annonce des résultats
on sait que c'est toujours un moment où
ça peut basculer alors tout à fait des
remous note que le solde analyse que
j'ai l'honneur de diriger bien de
cabinet politique à l'intention de la
céder à sa vie en fait dans des pays
comme la guinée le problème la crise ne
naît pas du processus électoral c'est à
l'annoncé des résultats qui a une
véritable c'est pourquoi je crains fort
que le lendemain électoral en guinée
soit très sanglant parce que les deux
parties sont dans une position figée
l'opposition estime monsieur diallo
estime qu'il est à sa troisième
tentative
fort de l'engouement faire de la
majorité de militants qu'il a il est
persuadé d'être victorieux de l'élection
et michel par condé ne peut pas avoir
que tous les efforts qu'il a faits de
changer une constitution dans des
conditions vraiment un congolais et
accepté sa défaite et je pense que la
cédéao devaient aujourd'hui être au
chevet de la guinée parce que le line up
électoral d'annuler
c'est la troisième élection libre
élections pluralistes en tout cas dans
ce pays depuis 1958 deux mandats pour
alpha condé en 2010 et en 2015
il reste néanmoins populaire l alpha
condé premier chef d'état en tout cas
avoir été élu démocratiquement
joe papp sa popularité ce qui est
navrant un gain de cause je voudrais
tout cas c'est un pays qui n'a pas connu
d'alternance et beaucoup de guinée avait
inspiré à l'arrivée de mr condé de la
guinée allait connaître une alternance
pour une raison très simple
d'abord tu vu son passé d'opposant
pendant des années au régime
sékou touré et lansana conté et surtout
l'expérience douloureuse de la prison
qu'il a eu à faire
les guinéens ont estimé qu'ils auraient
fait deux mandats et passer la main
permettre enfin à ce pays de connaître
une alternance
malheureusement les guinéens constate
aujourd'hui que il s'est accroché comme
beaucoup de chefs d'état d'afrique
il a eu sept ce qu'on appelle la maladie
du pouvoir je pense que lille va tout
faire pour être reconduit pour un
troisième mandat qui va entraîner une
véritable l'instabilité politique dans
la guinée quel est le bilan d'alpha
condé il ya toujours une grande misère
en guinée alors le paradoxe de ce pays
c'est que michel par contre je sais que
je vais appeler le poum la bauxite
c'est à dire en dix ans il s'est pas
intéressée aux eaux plus occupations
quotidiennes de guinette à dire l'accès
à l'eau l'accès aux soins de santé
primaires l'accès aux infrastructures il
a construit des hôtels et il a engagé ce
qu'on appelle une exploitation effrénée
de la bauxite
aujourd'hui la guinée en 2019 a été
exportée a produit 70 millions de tonnes
de bauxite a exporté 76 millions tonnes
dans le même temps la guinée si vous
prenez les chiffres de l'ordre de
l'office français de protection des
réfugiés
la guinée arrive en deuxième position en
terme de demandeurs d'asile derrière
l'afghanistan et pire le pire le pays
arrive en tête de mineurs non
accompagnés
parce que tous les guinéens de vue la
misère qui sévit dans le pays leur seule
solution c'est de quitter le pays et là
c'est le paradoxe c'est à dire que sur
le plan et à la bauxite qui a exploité
malheureusement les guinéens vivent
aujourd'hui dans une pauvreté extrême
merci beaucoup aliou barry d'avoir
répondu ce soir à nos questions sur arte
france
le cessez-le-feu dans le haut-karabagh
va-t-il tenir cette fois plus d'une
semaine après la signature d'une trêve
jamais appliqué entre l'azerbaïdjan et
l'arménie
les deux parties ont convenu de cesser
les hostilités hier soir un accord
décidé sous l'égide de la france et de
la russie membre du groupe de minsk et
qui est entrée en vigueur à minuit les
belligérants s'accuse déjà mutuellement
d'avoir repris les hostilités aux combes
quatre minutes c'est le temps qu'il aura
fallu pour que la trêve négociée
quelques heures plus tôt soit violé
quatre petites minutes après minuit
heure officielle du début de la trêve
les tirs azerbaïdjanais ont repris son
la porte parole du ministère arménien de
la défense violents à nouveau le
cessez-le-feu humanitaire l'ennemi a
effectué des tirs d'artillerie en
direction du nord entre 00h04 et 2h45 et
à lancer des roquettes vers le sud entre
2h20 et 2h45
des accusations que portent également
bas coût qui reprochent à l'armée
arménienne d'avoir violé la trêve
l'espoir de voir les combats cesser au
moins temporairement s'éloigne déjà
négociés sous l'égide du groupe de minsk
et plus particulièrement de la france
les injonctions de l'elysée à à cesser
le feu ne semble pas avoir payé ce
cessez le feu doit être inconditionnelle
et strictement respecté par les deux
parties la france y sera très attentive
et restera engagée pour que les
hostilités cessent durablement et que
des discussions crédible puisse
rapidement s'engager
une issue qui avait déjà connu le cessez
le feu négocié par moscou samedi dernier
alors qu'une trêve aurait permis aux
populations de panser leurs plaies
hier deux terribles bombardements ont
frappé la ville azéri de ganja faisant
au moins 13 morts parmi les civils selon
un bilan officiel
aujourd'hui les recherches se
poursuivent pour retrouver d'éventuels
survivants et en croire un conseiller du
président de la république non reconnue
duo carval à la trêve est en vigueur
mais seulement dans certaines zones
écoutez bien sûr que j'étais même vous
êtes tous informés qu'à partir du 18
octobre à minuit
une nouvelle trêve humanitaire aurait dû
entrer en vigueur au gym mutsch dont
nous rarement en général dans certaines
zones
elle est en vigueur n'ont jamais tué
boîte comme route mais vaut peut-être
encore un court trop charles marcoux
mais dans d'autres zones lenny poursuit
sa politique sournoise en essayant de
percer les défenses des forces d'artsakh
surpris proche périphérie d'un crime et
a paris une manifestation en soutien à
cette région contestée du haut karabagh
a eu lieu aujourd'hui
une manifestation à l'appel du conseil
de coordination des organisations
arméniennes de france des manifestants
qui demandent notamment la
reconnaissance du haut karabagh en tant
que république libre et indépendante
écoutez les c'est la quatrième
manifestation 12 d'organiser en france
depuis trois semaines
depuis que l'azerbaïdjan et la turquie
ont attaqué loca mamac l algérie pour
demander la paix pour exiger
effectivement des voix citoyenne ce qui
s'est levé pour demander que la
communauté internationale ont fait
respecter effectivement les cessez le
feu qui ont été signés à plusieurs
reprises à l'azerbaïdjan et l'arménie et
violée quelques minutes après leur
signature mal à certaines jambes
aujourd'hui on est là pour dénoncer la
guerre entre
la l'arménie le karabagh et
l'azerbaïdjan et pour dénoncer les
pertes de civils par des arbres qui sont
vendus par des groupes paris pays
occidentaux entre la france et israël
l'allemagne la part du gouvernement
français de reconnaître de reconnaître
l'artsakh d'arrêter de vendre des ventes
d armes à l'azerbaïdjan est de protéger
de protéger le peuple arménien le monde
se tait
et sam
mais dans tous mes efforts il faut que
le monde se réveille un pays où on n'est
vraiment pas beau
pas de forces militaires assez fort
contre la turquie il ya la terre battue
et c'est jour de vote est également en
bolivie aujourd'hui après la démission
d'evo morales les boliviens se sont
rendus aux urnes pour élire leur
président et selon les derniers sondages
un candidat arrive en tête pour
l'instant il s'agit de l'ancien premier
ancien ministre socialiste de l'économie
luis arce et qui arrivent en tête des
intentions de vote au premier tour
plus de 7 millions de boliviens sont
appelés à voter l'objectif est bien sûr
d'éviter une nouvelle crise politique
dans le pays
je pense que nous attendons tous le jour
des élections qui est demain et ici
comme vous le savez et devriez le savoir
ici dans la ville d'el alto tous une
bonne majorité un grand nombre
soutiennent l'ancien président evo
morales nous nous préparons pratiquement
tous donc tout le monde comme vous le
voyez et vous allez sur les marchés nous
préparons tous pour ce moment de crise
qui nous l'espérons ne sera pas trop
long mais qui viendra je pense que nous
devons tous aller aux élections et
essayer de ramener le peuple pouvoir
pour pas que nous soyons sans
gouvernement après 15 ans tout reste
pareil
nous ne sommes pas toujours avantagé par
le gouvernement ce que nous voulons
vraiment c'est la stabilité économique
parce que nous vivons au jour le jour
vis à vis il y a un an en octobre 2019
evo morales était réélu à la tête du
pays pour un quatrième mandat après un
scrutin controversé une élection qui
avait provoqué d'immenses manifestations
et poussait le président socialiste a
démissionné depuis la présidentielle a
été reportée à plusieurs reprises
retour en images sur cette crise
politique qui a secoué la bolivie ces
derniers mois
[Rires]
oh
[Musique]
[Rires]
oh
[Musique]
on
où
beaucoup
oh
[Musique]
au chili des manifestations aujourd'hui
pour commémorer le premier anniversaire
de la contestation sociale contre les
inégalités sur fond de violences
policières
un rassemblement sur la constitution
aura lieu dimanche prochain
maxime rosières et les 1000 google à
l'origine de la crise sociale
l'augmentation du prix du ticket de
métro
une hausse qui fait basculer le pays
dans une contestation inédite depuis les
années pinochet
la hausse du prix des transports publics
de cette fin de semaine était la goutte
qui fait déborder le vase
en réalité cette manifestation va à
l'encontre du système des manifestations
qui dégénèrent en affrontements avec la
police et en pillages faisant plusieurs
morts et de nombreux blessés
malgré l'annulation de la hausse du prix
des transports
le soulèvement continu et le président
au chilien doit décréter l'état
d'urgence
c'est contre ces criminels et non pas
contre les compatriotes qui manifestent
paisiblement que nous avons invoqué
l'état d'urgence dans le but de les
identifier de les poursuivre de les
juger et de les punir
aussi au cours de la semaine prochaine
je convoquerai une table de dialogue
large et transversales pour entendre la
voix et les propositions des différents
secteurs
mais surtout la voix de nos citoyens
devant la poursuite du mouvement le
président chilien annonce un référendum
pour changer la constitution héritée de
la dictature
une demande des manifestants un an après
le début de la contestation et alors que
le scrutin approche les chiliens
continuent de manifester mais ils sont
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus éthique nous
n'arriverons à une solution qu'une fois
toutes les demandes acceptées tant
qu'elles ne sont pas acceptés tant
qu'elles ne sont pas écrite avec du sang
rien n'aura changé jusqu'à ce que je
sens vraiment que nous avons accompli
quelque chose jusqu'à ce que quelque
chose change parce qu'en ce moment nous
avons un niveau de répression très élevé
il y a encore une énorme injustice
concernant le nombre de blessés et de
morts et de disparus du 18 octobre
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
des demandes qui restent lettre morte
pour l'instant seuls grands acquis ce
référendum dimanche prochain pour
changer la constitution
plus de 14 millions de chiliens sont
appelés à se prononcer et plus qu'une
remise en cause du président c'est le
système économique et politique chilien
que dénoncent les manifestants c'est
l'analyse de georges eo reina là il est
fondateur du blog franchie je pense que
les manifestations elles ne sont pas
contre pinera pinera s'est juste bale
élu président dès qui est là et qui a
qui est en marionnettes du système qui a
été imposée au chili en dictature et ses
systèmes a été malheureusement prolonger
pendant les trente ans de démocratie par
tous les gouvernements à des gauchers
des droites dépit madame bachelet
jusqu'à jusqu'à pinera est justement les
gens ils sont là parce qu'il ya un
ras-le-bol contre le système
les systèmes chilien c'est l'un des plus
inégalitaires au monde
il s'est fait un système néolibéral mais
il n'y a même pas de concurrence
économique puisque quelques familles
domine absolument toute la richesse du
pays
et c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité sur notre antenne
on se retrouve dans 30 minutes restez
avec nous
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]